it might seem as though in order to be
named the highest-paid movie actor of
the last decade one would have to star
in a good number of huge Hollywood hits
but with only a handful of roles over
the last 10 years it comes as something
of a surprise that Will Smith has been
crowned the king of Hollywood paychecks
the actor didn't totally dominate pop
culture in the 2010s like he had in the
1990s with The Fresh Prince of bel-air
and the bad boys franchise or in the
2000s with high-profile appearances in
everything from romantic comedies the
post-apocalyptic action errs to
oscar-nominated dramas instead the 2010
saw Smith taking quite a few dramatic
roles in films like focus concussion
collateral beauty and Gemini man he also
turned out appearances in two critical
failures as Floyd Lawton aka Deadshot in
the much-maligned
Suicide Squad and as Darrell Ward in
bright another David Ayer directed
venture Smith's final film of the 2010s
was different from all the
aforementioned others he voiced Lance
Stirling the world's most awesome spy in
the 20th Century Fox animated flick
spies in disguise opposite spider-man
star Tom Holland though Smith hasn't
exactly had a stellar critical record
for this decade of film releases there
has been one shining star men in black 3
it's been a long while now but men in
black 3 was released in this decade in
2012 to be exact and it earned Smith an
incredible 100 million dollar paycheck
according to The Hollywood Reporter
Smith walked away with that stack of
cash from the film's box office take
home in 2019 cash 100 million is nearly
112 million
further solidifying Smith as the top
earner of the decade for men in black 3
Smith reprised his role as Agent J one
last time for an upfront salary of 20
million dollars but secured in his
contract a whopping 10 percent of gross
income from the film which is where the
extra 80 million came from usually after
release supplementary compensation for
an actor is calculated by net profit
once studio bills and marketing expenses
are paid so a deal like Smith's is
extraordinary franchise star power is
what keeps sequels alive and Men
Studios have grown eager to shell out
money to retain actors or in Smith's
case bring them back an entire decade
after the previous iteration the men in
black 3 production rolled out the
metaphorical red carpet for Smith all
throughout shooting as well and was even
ignoble II memorialized in New York Post
spreads complaining about the luxurious
trailers Smith brought along for on
location shoots where'd you get the car
and the suit I stole them both a car
from your wife suit from your
grandmother bringing back the namesake
men in black was an extremely expensive
venture but in the end it paid off men
in black 3 grossed the most money of the
franchise's history including the most
recent and poorly performing for a men
and black International it's unlikely
Smith will ever return to the MIB
franchise and truthfully after a payday
like the one he received from men in
black 3 he doesn't really need to
knowing that Smith's 2010's Hall came
from a blockbuster franchise isn't
surprising what is surprising is that
the franchise was anything other than
the Marvel Cinematic Universe Iron Man's
2008 release donned our new blockbuster
movie going era and the 2010s saw it
becoming a franchise perpetuating
machine profits had never been greater
for the tentpole release than they were
in the 2010s and that's been nothing but
good for film studios and the actors who
negotiate themselves into long-term
contracts it's the kind of money that
will not only set them for life but also
pay their great grand children's college
tuitions Robert Downey jr. has been
without a doubt Marvel's reigning star
but still the Iron Man lead couldn't
take the title of the top earning actor
of the 2010s even with 75 million
dollars for Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame each our DJ actually
did come in second place for single film
income behind Smith check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stars
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]